on se met au boulot je te suis
au boulot 530
000 lycéens ont planché sur l'épreuve de
philosophie du baccalauréat ce matin
traditionnellement c'était la première
des épreuves de l'examen mais avec la
réforme elle passe désormais après les
spécialités la plupart des candidats
sont déjà assurés d'avoir leur diplôme
quel que soit leur note en philosophie
ce qui limite l'enjeu du jour et ça ce
sont dans l'attitude des lycéens que
nous avons croisés du coup elles ont
révisé cette matière avant-hier
seulement sur leur portable et en
écoutant de la musique source
d'inspiration Nekfeu qui parle aussi de
bah du coup un chanteur qui parle aussi
de la liberté que ce soit dans les
banlieues ou que ce soit à travers son
écriture le fait d'être libre d'écrire
ce qu'on veut un este de moderne sans
oublier les anciens on peut s'aider du
rap mais quand même réutiliser Sartre et
des cartes parce que on veut quand même
des bonnes notes
mais trop sympa et tu me vois beaucoup
plus jeune que ce que je suis en réalité
merci beaucoup Lucas merci
ok d'accord
je suis en train de me dire que moi si
j'avais été fils d'instituteur je pense
que je me serais levé la nuit
discrètement en cas de contrôle le
lendemain hein vous savez pour aller
fouiller dans le sac hein oui mais ça
enfant eux sont honnêtes oui
contrairement à moi de toute façon moi
j'ai pas été confronté à ça donc en fait
je suis honnête
le mieux c'est d'aller encore plus loin
c'est les lunettes connectées les
lunettes qui vont qui sont équipées
d'une caméra exactement en fait elles
prennent en photo le sujet elle l'envoie
à la personne qui est à l'extérieur et
mieux encore dans les montures des
lunettes vous avez des écouteurs à
conduction osseuse et donc vous entendez
ce que la personne vous dit à distance
donc elle peut vous donner toutes les
réponses au sujet évidemment là encore
je vous dis c'est pas pour donner de
mauvaise idée aux gens en fait on trouve
ça hyper tellement il y a un magasin
spécialisé juste à côté de chez moi
c'est pour ça que j'ai pensé à ce sujet
vraiment c'est en passant devant le
magasin et cette épreuve 2023 de
philosophie a donné lieu à une
confrontation inédite entre deux
candidats le célèbre philosophe et
l'intelligence artificielle tu as des
petits ils ont eu une heure pour rédiger
une dissertation sur un des sujets du
bac le bonheur est-il à faire de raison
pour la petite histoire bien sûr chez le
GPD a déjà fini son sa copie donc on est
en train de voilà retranscrire la copie
en mode manuscrit donc on a une copie a
copié B des premières phrases on peut
voir la différence et je pense qu'on a
deviné qui avait écrit quoi en fait même
dès les premiers mots une pipe sur
lequel est indiqué ceci n'est pas une
pipe et donc c'est un c'est un clin
d'oeil évident de Dali mais il
complexifie encore plus la démarche
c'est à dire que le tableau de Magritte
ce n'est effectivement pas une pipe
puisque c'est une peinture de pipe en
revanche ça c'est bien une assiette et
Dali nous explique que ce n'est pas une
assiette donc on y comprend plus rien
les notes 11 et 20
[Rires]
pas du tout j'avais eu peur comme tout
le monde et voilà c'est intéressant
c'est de voir que même si élaboré
soit-il un logiciel ne peut pas encore
accomplir cet exercice convenablement et
il ne pourra vraisemblablement jamais le
faire il a obtenu la moyenne il a obtenu
la note qu'on donne à la à l'élève qui
dit oui non peut-être dès l'invasion de
l'Ukraine le principal fabricant
américain du viagra a décidé de stopper
net ces livraisons vers la Russie et la
pénurie est là-bas devenue carrément une
affaire d'état en février le Kremlin a
donné son autorisation pour lancer des
essais cliniques sur son territoire et
36 entreprises ont reçu un agrément ça
va chef vous faites une drôle de tête
mais c'est inscrit ou quoi ce chef là il
me dégoûte attention chef vous êtes à
deux doigts de vous faire démasquer et
vous connaissez Gérard évidemment pas du
tout
non mais il est habitué après deux mois
de tournage ensemble
le sexe le soir permettrait de mieux
dormir dans leur étude les scientifiques
qui ont interrogé plusieurs personnes
affirment que la libération d'hormones
dont l'endorphine après avoir fait
crac-crac badaboum permettrait de se
sentir libéré moins stressé et donc de
trouver le sommeil plus facilement avec
qui avec Raymond Domenech
[Musique]
j'ai pas que ça à faire c'est vrai oh là
là
j'aime beaucoup ce que tu as dit mais il
t'aime beaucoup
je l'aime beaucoup surtout depuis 2006
et 2008
et pour les célibataires pas
d'inquiétude puisqu'il se produirait le
même phénomène avec des plaisirs
solitaires depuis les plages de Floride
on est plutôt habitué à voir des requins
mais cette fois c'est un petit ours qui
a attiré l'attention avant de sortir de
l'eau parmi les nombreux baigneurs
surpris certains ont filmé la scène
avant de la partager sur les réseaux
sociaux un ours qui se baigne en Floride
ne serait pas si rare mais généralement
c'est loin des regards reste une
inconnue d'où venait cette ourse arrivé
sur une plage de la ville nommée